ich werde in diesem video zeigen wie cdu
leute lügen wie sie sich augenscheinlich
an verschiedenen kriegsverbrechen
beteiligen wie sie propaganda und
unwahrheiten gegen die junge generation
einsetzen der typ sieht aus wie jemand
der früher auf dem schulhof sehr wächst
wohne hallo ich bin philipp amthor
cdu-bundestagsabgeordneter und ich
schaue mir heute so wiedemann
wir sitzen jetzt mit der cdu aus also
diese noch bestimmt kompetenter und
würden doch nicht so klare
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse und einen
überwältigenden konsens über notwendiges
verhalten aha was das auch ist weiß ich
nicht einfach ignorieren wenn wir diese
1,5 grad einhalten wollen hat die ganze
menschheit nur noch eine bestimmte menge
von co2 die sie in die luftballon darf
dieser typ muss sie mal richtig eine
alte ballack zum vergleich allein die
über 70-jährigen haben anderthalb mal so
viele stimmen wie alle unter 30 jährigen
die rentner entscheiden also mehr über
unsere zukunft obwohl sie diese zukunft
gar nicht mehr miterleben werden
deswegen flirten tor mit dem rentner
budgets aber nicht nur die tiere sterben
wir kriegen auch ein kleines goodie bag
es wird dann nämlich mehr krankheiten
für uns geben also näher denn je mehr
infektionskrankheiten und allergien gp
lungenkrebs ist das was gut ist auch für
unsere zeit und wer es nicht mitbekommen
hat hunderttausende schüler streiken für
die anerkennung der wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse die karte auf dem schulhof
probleme am ein stell dich mal vor
europa ist im garten und die buddelt da
so die möhren aus die sie gesät hat vor
ein paar monaten und plötzlich ist sie
weckt explodiert einfach eure ganze ohne
eine alte oma ab ball angeht immer da
die nicht gar nichts wählt bitte nicht
die spd wählt bitte nicht die cdu wählt
bitte nicht die csu wenn ich so vater
wäre hätte ich ihn an einen wanderzirkus
fasching
thomas ist ein ganz kreativer typ aber
galilei ist ein level das habe ich
bisher noch nicht erreicht wenn ihr
weitere videos sehen wollt hier fürs
abonnieren hier unten beides kann ich
euch empfehlen
[Musik]